i may have seen all the episodes of
vikings
so uh i'm you know happy to be able to
talk to you
um as a fan um but i want to start with
the most important question which is um
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
oh wow that's a very good question um
i'm recently watching queen's gamuts i
thought that's a really fun
thing to be involved in and um i'm
actually working with
william horberg who's also produced on
that and producing uh next movie with
him
so been catching up on on on
this series um so i think that's the one
thing that comes to my mind
right now got it um what movie do you
think
you've seen the most
well that's a tough question when i was
a kid i was a big fan of annie
so i think as a kid i've probably seen
that movie probably
a hundred times you know every saturday
it was
one of those things that after saturday
ukrainian school
my mom would um put it on after
our when we could come home and it was
kind of more of a routine i think i
could probably recite
every single line in that movie um so i
would have to say that
uh also shawn shank redemption as an
adult i've seen that movie and
i can watch it moving day in day out and
never get bored of that and
and still be inspired by that movie as
well um
that's a movie that if it comes on tv
you can't turn away
you have to watch it no completely do
you remember what it was
when you were younger that said uh that
got you into the entertainment industry
that got you
excited about the prospect of being an
actor
gosh i think there wasn't necessarily
well
actually there is i had a cousin um who
was
the very first um
music uh dj really uh
or video dj uh her name was samantha
taylor in canada she worked for mtv
and she was my cousin the so she was
kind of the older cousin that was
famous and on television and um i used
to
you know being in greece school used to
watch all the time and she would have
these record albums
that with her face on and i would take
it to school and
have her autograph it and try to sell it
because it was just one of those things
that was so proud to be
to know somebody that was on tv and um
and getting a chance to to be inspired
that
you can do it i come from a small town
outside of toronto called etobicoke
and um didn't know anybody in the
industry other than her
and the possibility to getting a chance
to
tell stories um either in front of the
camera as an actor or as a director for
me has always been
inspiring and as a even as a teenager
started directing
and writing plays i got a scholarship
actually from out of high school
for for directing and it's of and
and i directed uh several plays and
that's really inspired me to
be a director even today uh i know
you've uh directed a few episodes uh
but so i want to get into marksman real
quick um
so i'm a huge liam neeson fan i'm
assuming you're also a huge liam neeson
fan
so i guess i want to know what did you
pay to be in the marksman
did i pay i'm totally joking with you
i'm being
i'm i'm just yeah i know what you're
exactly just saying
so my agents called me and uh they told
me that
this is a straight offer for liam neeson
movie and you get a chance to play
opposite him and play his his daughter
his stepdaughter
and um i think it was a quick shoot for
me was like it was five days but i just
wanted to
be oppositely nissan for me that was a
no-brainer of course i've been a fan of
his
since the schindler's list days and even
taken and um getting a chance to be
opposite him was my main draw
and um and uh i'm really glad i did it
because he's such a warm
loving human being and as an actor very
giving
uh there were times where they were
a lot of my scenes were on the phone and
here's liam neeson who
carrying the entire movie works every
single day but came in
on his days off and actually sat there
just to read
off camera lines over um a telephone for
me because that's what a giving actor he
is and that's something that was very
touching and inspiring and um something
that
i will never forget so thank you liam
yeah i think a lot of people that don't
understand movie making
don't realize that when you're on a
phone often you're just
like it's an aed offset reading stuff
it's not the actual person you're
talking to
it's true and as an actor you
sometimes don't have that luxury to work
with at the other times there's times
we're also even in a scene and if the
other person has to
be shot out for whatever reason or
prepare for the next scene it has to be
turned over in hair and makeup
you're stuck with sometimes just reading
with on a blank wall
or or with an a.d um and this is an
opportunity where
he didn't have to be there at all it was
his day off it was over the phone
and i fully expected 80 to do it but he
was there he just showed up in his
in his sweats and he's like okay let's
do this i'm here for you
and that was really um inspiring and
really
i love to love them for that did you
have more people that wanted to visit
you when you were filming marksman
because of liam neeson or vikings
because of vikings
that's a good question we shot in
albuquerque so pretty much in the middle
of nowhere
um yes there were times when we were in
the city and people used to gather
around and
um and you never know who's everyone's
trying to take pictures of because me
and lisa were together but he's
he obviously has a huge fan base and um
we were pretty lucky enough to be shot
also shooting in the middle of nowhere
so we had a chance just to be by
ourselves and
um hang out with ourselves so we were
untouched in a lot of ways and that's
one of the advantages of shooting in
albuquerque such fast landscapes
so yeah that's pretty much it
one of the things is when you're a fan
of someone's work
like liam um and i know like you know
people geek out like uh
i guess what i'm curious is do you ever
as a fan want to geek out with him
or do you maintain that professional
distance because you're also an actor
and you know when you're working maybe
you don't want to talk about other stuff
you want to be focused in the moment
i prefer not to talk about the scenes
for me as an actor it's for me the most
important thing is to find a connection
and it could be about anything we talked
about skiing we talked about a ukrainian
pierogies we talked about living in new
york and his real estate we talked about
um ireland because he's obviously irish
and he's lived there for seven years
and for me that is more important than
actually necessarily talking about the
scene
because then as an actor as a human
being i find a connection with him
and find things that i can really tap
into so when the camera rolls
i can feel um definitely closer to him
and i can definitely find a connection
that
um that that is real because because
there is a history already there
that even if it's short-lived of talking
about
you know the pubs in dublin or
our favorite local restaurant in in
dublin um that there's definitely
something there that's
that's already real and uh
easier for me to grab i would have just
spent the entire time talking about
guinness and why it's so much better in
dublin
but anyway um so one of the things i
want to switch subjects for a second
when you sign on for a television show
um
getting to make a pilot is like winning
the lottery getting
to do a first season is it's so rare
um when you signed on for vikings did
you have any inkling that this thing
could actually
make it multiple seasons and be as
popular as it was
if i'm being honest with you yes i knew
i knew it was going to be something
special i read
first two episodes i read and being a
huge fan of michael hurst
and getting a chance to facetime him or
actually skype then
and to have his um
story unfold and the way he sees solid
he definitely saw multiple seasons
and he was ready for it and planned for
it so i knew that it was going to go for
a long time i think i had about five or
six days after i got hired to get on a
plane and move my entire life to ireland
um and i i prepared for it i really did
i kind of had an
idea that i was going to be near for a
long haul i did not know that my
character was going to last till the end
you know that is something that i i
think originally when i was told i was
told maybe a couple years maybe three
um and it was supposed to be a story
about the
sons of ragnaros after that and but i
know the fans were really
um involved in and even writing my
cohorts letters and making sure i would
stay on board um i think they even
threatened him
um but it's it was nice to be able to
tell like at this story even as a
grandmother
and frankly and um definitely past her
prime
and as an actor that's it's definitely
um has been a creative experience
for me to be able to dive into a full
journey as like that even as a farmer to
now as a grandmother and you don't
really have that opportunity
very often if people are lucky as actors
once in their life to have a role that's
really
um monumental in
in their uh in their journey as an actor
and i definitely feel that lagrange
playing lack of that has been that for
me and
hopefully it won't be the last um but
i'm really honored to be part of that
uh i actually got to do a long interview
with michael i guess two weeks ago now
two three weeks ago
and one of the things that i still can't
believe is
with any tv show there's usually a
writer's room where they're pitching
ideas and what's so crazy about vikings
that a lot of people don't realize is
michael wrote every episode every single
episode i don't think that there is
any writer after seven seasons
really well six and a half it's just
crazy how many episodes hundreds of
episodes
to write every single episode and has it
all in his head without
a writing partner yeah it's absolutely
unbelievable
and um something that he's i know very
very proud of
and as an actor you don't have you have
that such a luxury to be able to
create a character with the creator and
the writer
to bring your personal life um
into the conversations so he can write
for you
and it was probably um
i really it turned into a habit that
after after every script i would call
michael and he would come in and we
would have dinner
and we would break down the story and i
would tell him about my life what's
happening in my
in my journey and i could next episode i
see him
writing a little bit about that in there
and um and i think that
actually you feel very much involved
that you're part of lagretha's
development and you as an actor wanna
you dive in because it's really a part
of you
it's hard to even tell the difference
sometimes especially after so many years
of playing one character to separate
yourself
from who she is versus who you are in a
lot of ways especially when
you're this involved with the with the
writer and and telling lagreta's
story and really your story did you was
it your idea
to have your uh to have lagatha die
where she did
was it like were you leaving to do
something else was it michael saying
this is your time like how did that all
come about oh no i thought i was gonna
go a lot earlier
i'm not gonna lie to you i definitely
was ready to go earlier um only just
because i think
you know these are the vikings times the
the majority of
lifespan was i think 38 30 and 40 at
that time and i'm already pushing
up of high 50 60s as as a grandmother
um so we have to keep somewhat kind of
into
into the history of it all um
but michael didn't necessarily really
want to let me go but
there has to be a time where where if
i'm gonna go
um let's write me something fantastic
and amazing
and i couldn't ask for a better ending
ever
and i really wanted to direct and for me
to direct i
needed to also i get a chance to do
season six
and um and it was important for me to
get behind the camera to be able to
uh it's really hard to do as an actor
and director at the same time
so i i was couldn't be happier on how
michael
wrote lagretha's ending and really the
funeral that she gave that he gave her
and the legacy that
even continues on to this final season
that she's still in there
through memories and through uh the plot
and story lines
i actually i was just going to say that
i actually lost you there because of my
computer but i'm glad it all worked out
i i know i i'm just about out of time
just want to ask one last thing i want
to say congrats on the success of your
abc show
um being part of two successful shows is
like a miracle
um do you think that if it gets picked
up for a second season which is looking
likely based on your recent pickup of
more episodes
do you envision each season could be
like a different crime
like what are you thinking or have you
guys talked about something like that
well thank you um i i the way i choose
project is really
who the creators are obviously michael
hurst for vikings and david kelly for
big sky is
the main reason i signed on to this um
a little nervous about being on a
network and in terms of creatively how
to be able to push the boundaries as an
artist
to to um to keep it raw and it feels
more like a cable show
uh but i think the vision has been since
it's based on a series of books
is to tell and make it a serialized
drama but to tell
uh multiple books within one season so
probably two we're focusing on i know
that we're about to start
um another book next episode
to for the remainder of the finale of
the last
we got ordered for six more so we
finished one book
um which was going to be wrapped up
officially in episode
i would think the one which we just
shootings episode 9
and then um in episode 10 it's going to
be more of a standalone episode and 11
to
16 will be another book so
and i think that there's that's always
such an opportunity that format is
interesting because we can bring in some
really powerful guest stars
and some great actors that are willing
to really dive into strong media
material either as villains or as
um great uh supporting actors that can
tell the story
in a short uh format and
um i'm excited about the casting choices
and hopefully abc really
uh is bold with their choices and the
week create
great storylines that people will be
intrigued by it
um i know i gotta go i'm just gonna say
that uh that's really smart
filmmaking not trying to carry one
storyline for 16 episodes
um i think that's going to make your
show much more successful
uh not having to you know you know what
i mean when it you were
supposed to get on the second storyline
much earlier but we're waiting for a
pick up
and maybe too long to do it so we i just
noticed them extending this one
you know uh but i definitely agree with
you i think that's definitely a way to
keep everything moving faster and
um definitely keep the interest up 100
listen congrats on everything um
seriously i really mean that good luck
with the rest of your interviews
have a fantastic day thank you